c'est un écrin de verdure au coeur de la
ville une ancienne friche de
seine-saint-denis devenue la ferme
pédagogique de la butte pinson 5000
mètres carrés entretenue par des
employés en service civique ou des
jeunes condamnés à des travaux d'intérêt
général pour à tony momoh t/t sur
l'étape signé quentin monia venir tu es
au rangement ont dénoncé son atelier aux
6es et c'est bon et c'est parti le site
est géré par les fermiers de la
francilienne
l'association fait le pari de la
réinsertion des jeunes sous main de
justice
grâce aux travaux de la ferme du
maraîchage à la construction alors je
m'appelle dijan j'ai 22 ans et je fais
de l'éco construction
ça consiste à fabriquer des matériaux en
bois de récupération simplement
aujourd'hui en service civique
dylan a d'abord connu la ferme on y
purgeant une peine de travaux d'intérêt
général
la fin d'un parcours long et difficile
qui ai commencé très tôt elle avait des
difficultés à s'occuper de nous à était
dépressif très dépressif
du coup il a demandé à ce qu'on soit
placé en famille d'accueil et de soin
mais trois ans jusqu'à mes 18 ans je te
placer deux familles d'accueil en foyer
d'hébergement dylan va connaître
plusieurs places noms successifs
une enfance instable qui glisse
progressivement vers la délinquance il
commet son premier délit à 16 ans des
vols et cambriolages répéter vont
finalement le conduire en prison
j'étais incarcéré le 21 novembre 2014
exactement j'avais presque avoir 18 ans
dans deux mois elle j'étais dans une
maison d'arrêt normales avec des majeurs
mais sauf que justement 20 quartiers
pour mineurs en maison d'arrêt a parlé
cours l'éducatrice qui venez nous voir
voyez personne ne sortait pas on dit que
tu dois manger on dit que la rue doit
sortir en promenade
on dit que tu dois aller en cours on dit
que tout en fait et sa voix c'est dur
quand on décide pourtant assez dur dylan
va passer quatre mois en prison entre en
tant que mineur il en ressort majeur est
de 18 ans et 2 mois sans un sou en poche
l'administration mais c'est normal merde
complètement faut savoir que je gagnais
250 euros en formation que j'ai fait
deux mois
j'avais même pas assez pour payer mon
billet trains complets je rentrais en
fraude de limoges en normandie
c'est là que c'est devenu vraiment le
plus compliqué en fait dans ma vie aller
à droite à gauche dans la famille je
fais ça pendant deux ans un moment la
famille on en a marre quoi je me suis
retrouvé complètement seul en colère
complètement
livré à lui même dylan va vite récidive
est entré dans la délinquance
à 16 ans il a été pris en charge par la
justice des mineurs jusqu'à ses 18 ans
un système censé aider et protéger
l'adolescent qu'il était mais qui a
échoué à lui offrir une chance de
réinsertion comme à bien d'autres jeunes
condamnés à des peine d'enfermement
[Musique]
on
le
[Musique]
tron
e
en france un enfant ne peut être jugé de
la même manière qu'un adulte la justice
des mineurs et spécialisés elle est
basée sur un texte fondateur
l'ordonnancé du 2 février 1945
l'esprit leur danse de 45 c'est vraiment
que l'enfant l'adolescent est un adulte
en devenir est pas un adulte en
miniature et que donc c'est un être qui
en construction et à qui on doit
appliquer des règles particulières et
aussi privilégier l'éducatif sur le
répressif c'est à dire suite à un acte
de délinquance c'est le contexte
familial le contexte éducatif qui va
être regardé pour essayer d'agir au plus
près et au plus vite auprès de cet
enfant qui considérait comme comme un
enfant en danger
un mineur n'est donc en théorie envoyé
en prison qu'en dernier recours quand
toutes les autres solutions sont épuisés
mais depuis une vingtaine d'années
l'ordonnancé du 2 février 1945 a été
modifié à de nombreuses reprises dans un
sens plus répressifs
depuis le début des années 2000 il ya un
vrai tournant législatif orchestré tant
par les majorités de droite que de
gauche
on va dire qu'ils donnent un caractère
beaucoup plus sécuritaire à la
législation pour mineurs et qui la font
de plus en plus depuis on peut dire
maintenant une petite vingtaine d'années
la rapprocher de la législation pour les
adultes
on peut prendre l'exemple de la création
de la présentation immédiate par exemple
qui est une forme de comparution
immédiate pour les enfants c'est à dire
qu'un mineur avant de passer devant un
tribunal a toujours passer par la phase
juge des enfants pour essayer de
recueillir des éléments sur sa
personnalité sur sa famille sur son
milieu et surtout sur les moyens qui lui
permettrait d'évoluer au mieux dans la
présentation immédiate ça c'est ap et
donc là ça va amener des mesures
beaucoup plus sévères et notamment des
mesures
incarcération en 20 ans le taux de
réponse pénale pour les affaires
impliquant des mineurs est passé de 60 à
94%
sans pour autant que la délinquance
juvénile n'augmente près de 860 jeunes
de moins de 18 ans vivent aujourd'hui
derrière les barreaux
c'est dans ce contexte qu'une mission
d'information sénatoriale s'est ouverte
son but faire le point sur les chances
de réinsertion offertes aux jeunes
condamnés à des peine d'enfermement
[Musique]
les sénateurs se sont donc intéressés
aux deux types de prison accueillant des
jeunes âgés d'au moins 13 ans les
établissements pénitentiaires pour
mineurs et les quartiers pour mineurs
des maisons d'arrêt ils sont incarcérés
sur décision d'un juge est répartie en
fonction des places disponibles
les deux tiers des jeunes détenus vivent
dans un quartier pour mineurs
la france en compte 44 les sénateurs ont
choisi de visiter le plus grand du pays
celui de villepinte en seine-saint-denis
donc le bâtiment mais tim reif à
l'excentris qui avait dépensé au départ
pour accueillir des femmes et donc n'a
jamais accueilli de femmes et donc les
deux ailes qui sont ici sur des ailes
dédié aux quartiers mineurs
les quartiers pour mineurs sont des
espaces aménagés dans les prisons pour
que les jeunes de moins de 18 ans soit
des tenues à l'écart des adultes
du moins en théorie et puis là vous
voyez dans les hôpitaux faisaient payer
millions donc avec des sacs poubelles
qui daterait de l'étanchéité mineurs
majeur dans une structure qui n'est pas
le quartier pour mineurs de villepinte
peut accueillir 40 jeunes au moment de
notre visite 37 y sont détenus
nous ne pourrons pas voir leurs cellules
qu'ils occupent seuls contrairement au
majeur parce qu'ils ont moins de 18 ans
les jeunes sont censés avoir des
conditions de détention et un emploi du
temps spécifique
pour savoir si tout le monde est tombé
après on leur sert le petit-déjeuner et
après il ya le scolaire met en place du
scolaire et après une heure de promenade
par jour pour seulement une heure de
promenade par jour les sénateurs sont
dubitatifs que ces foules venues
j'entends 12 heures d'enseignement par
semaine remplie de dinan
leurs craintes se confirment lors de
cette rencontre organisée avec certains
détenus que nous ne sommes pas autorisés
à filmer les jeunes disent rester
enfermé 23 heures sur 24 dans leurs
cellules le week end et réclame plus
d'heures de cours
comme l'a dit un des jeunes qui a
accepté d'être de nous rencontrer ses 35
heures de cours à l'école lui était en
troisième aujourd'hui c'est cette part
ces sept heures par semaine
donc il est évident que les conditions
de réinsertion sont notoirement
insuffisantes
devant les sénateurs les jeunes se
plaignent de la violence dans
l'établissement une violence également
dénoncé par un syndicat d'éducateurs
dans les promenades ya des règlements de
compte
est-ce que ça c'est les enfants qui nous
dit ça c'est que quand il ya qu un seul
surveillant à la pour la promenade
ils ont ordre de ne pas intervenir
puisque en gros ils vont être seul pour
40 personnes ou 20 et ils peuvent pas
rivaliser on est quasiment tout le temps
à 100 % d'occupation a même connu des
pics avec un sureffectif avec 42 voire
43 mineurs pour 40 places ce qui
effectivement être très compliqué
puisque d'abord la loi empêche la
cellule man x
les détenus en général et en particulier
pour les mineurs et puis du coup des
problèmes de cohabitat de cohabitation
et de prise en charge puisque voilà des
moyens sont sur les mêmes qu'il y ait 20
30 ou 40 mineurs en ile-de-france les
quartiers pour mineurs fonctionne à flux
tendu en 2017 tous ont été au moins une
fois en situation de suroccupation déjà
le nombre de jeunes qui sont pris en
charge
une quarantaine c'est énorme la prise en
charge individualisée ne peut pas se
faire correctement
je pense que c'est pas la structure la
meilleure pour les jeunes personnel
insuffisant violence programmes
scolaires plus qu'elle léger les
quartiers pour mineurs n'offrent pas les
meilleures conditions de réinsertion
jeunes
patino aurait ignoré
[Musique]
pour recentrer la détention des jeunes
sur l'action éducative un nouveau type
de prison a été créé en 2002 les opm
établissement pénitentiaire pour mineurs
celui de marseille a ouvert ses portes
en 2007
le pm nous stoppa lien secrétaire de
direction intérimaire nouvellement ici
contrairement au quartier pour mineurs
les opm sont des prisons exclusivement
réservé aux mineurs elles ont davantage
de moyens
de quoi assurer aux jeunes 19h de
scolarité par semaine
[Musique]
j'aime bien écouter on arrive à
contourner les difficultés en a donc dix
enseignants qui interviennent à temps
plein sur lequel les jeunes ont accès à
des infrastructures sportives un gymnase
couvert une salle de musculation
il ne mange pas seuls dans leur cellule
c'est l'une des particularités des
établissements pour mineurs avoir
parlementé d'hébergement arrêt victoire
en sachant que du coup ces
apprentissages aussi dans un certain
nombre de règles c'est m
les conditions de détention semble
meilleure que dans les quartiers pour
mineurs
mais les 6 pm construit depuis 2007 ne
peuvent accueillir qu'un tiers des
jeunes incarcérés
lorsqu'un juge ordonne l'emprisonnement
le détenu est envoyé en quartier pour
mineurs ou en ep m
en fonction des places disponibles
l'établissement de marseille en compte
on peut avoir des fluctuations
importantes là par exemple aujourd'hui
on est à 45
mais au mois de février on a pu remonter
jusqu'à 58 alors à 58
bien évidemment on n'est pas en
situation de sur recouvrement mais
nécessairement ça complique les
affectations en cellule et la prévention
d'un certain nombre de risques comme par
exemple est-ce que violence alors on est
sur des unités des berges de dix mineurs
près de 90% des jeunes détenus sont des
prévenus en attente de jugement
ils ne resteront ici que 3 - en moyenne
un temps souvent trop court pour mener
un vrai travail de réinsertion et
prévenir la récidive plus qu'on utilise
en détention et plus il retourne en
détention c'est à dire que on n'a plus
d'autre arme visiblement les magistrats
sont désarmés pour un homme qui passait
une fois en prison
la réponse allemande soit apprise on est
la réponse suivante sera encore la
prison un mineur qui a été incarcéré qui
a connu la détention à 69 % de chances
d'y retourner dans les trois ans 75 les
cinq ans ce qui laisse à penser que
l'outil n'est pas aussi dissuasif que ce
qu'on espérait en tout cas de ce qu'on
pense quand on essaie de 2 m un arrêt
après l'arrêt un comportement qui n'est
pas acceptable
donc il faut essayer de trouver des
mesures d'accompagnement renforcé mais
qu'ils soient pas forcément derrière des
barreaux
pour tenter de trouver une alternative à
l'incarcération
un nouveau type de structure a été
imaginé or des prisons à quelques
kilomètres dans le 9e arrondissement de
marseille
le cef centre éducatif fermé accueilli
une dizaine de jeunes âgés de 16 à 18
ans ils sont multirécidivistes
la plupart sont ici pour vol ou trafic
de stupéfiants piment l'un d'entre eux
suisse ce matin un atelier jardinage
piment de cayenne à 9 et u va les placer
comme tu avais fait la nar fois et cb
répartir ça fait ça et là tu rends
compte 40 cm en main ici 40 cm temps
mais alors avant d'être placés ici ils
aient été détenues lpm de marseille pour
protéger son anonymat et celui des
autres mineurs nous ne pouvons pas
mentionné les faits qui les ont conduits
devant la justice
c'est une chance tant que présence du
coup ces ars en ré à passer mieux venir
ici dans un cv d'avoir des activités
tous actes restent un fameux la journée
créé en 2002 les cff accueille douze
jeunes maximum pour des séjours de six
mois renouvelable une fois
c'est leur juge qui a opté pour cette
alternative à l'incarcération
les jeunes multirécidivistes sont placés
dans le cadre d'un contrôle judiciaire
ou en sursis avec mise à l'épreuve
un contrat passé avec le juge qui
comporte des règles à respecter
une sorte de dernière chance avant la
prison c'est effectivement un cadre qui
a très clairement fixée par le magistrat
avec des obligations une obligation de
suivi psychologique l'obligation de
suivre une formation
et effectivement dans le parcours se
couperaient en tant que telle existe si
effectivement il ya des incartades s'il
ya dix d'autres délits avec des notes
d'information magistrats qui sont
envoyées aux magistrats et pour lequel
il risque
ils peuvent risquer à l'incarcération
les cff ne sont pas officiellement
considérés comme des lieux d'enfermement
au cours de leur séjour les jeunes sont
progressivement autorisés à sortir
parfois seul pour passer le week-end
dans leur famille parfois accompagnés
d'un éducateur comme laurent pour son
atelier et chaque et socialisation
il emmène ce matin l'un des jeunes à la
terrasse d'un café à l'extérieur du
centre
avec 60 a pas 36 solutions est ce que ça
marche
donc il ya échec est ce que quelqu'un
peut venir à manger adam pearson donc
d'ailleurs les échecs c'est un prétexte
à la conversation
c'est aussi bon ça c'est c'est une
occasion de sortir à l'extérieur
j'y tiens quoi le but justement on voit
dans des occasions comme ça où on est
ensemble ils me font part de la rave on
va dire quoi je vais d'ailleurs je leur
demande c'est que ce serait quoi sert
elle et puis on va essayer de voir si
c'est possible
dans bien des cas c'est possible c'est
encore possible
un rêve ou tout simplement un projet
professionnel
ce qu'on va faire ce matin c'est que
vous allez relire en fait ce dossier une
fois que vous l'avez bien en tête
vous allez me faire une restitution à
l'oral d'accord c'est à partir des
aspirations des jeunes et de leur
parcours que l'on construit ici un
projet d'insertion sur mesure avec un
emploi du temps individualisé
franchement si on ne peut pas trop ici
bon après c'est bien d'être avec un
projet professionnel
c'est mieux de devenir non mais d'éviter
la présence d'une seconde chance si les
conditions de vie n'ont rien à voir avec
la prison mais les jeunes restent
constamment surveillé par les éducateurs
qui ont les clés de toutes les portes y
compris des chambres au moment de notre
visite
deux jeunes sont en fugue une situation
loin d'être inhabituel
malgré les hauts grillages et la
vidéosurveillance on se sent un peu
enfermé un de liberté parce qu il veut
son tour tensions entre dont les
éducateurs mois plupart des jeunes que
j'ouvrais le prennent mal et je pense
pas y croire il reste deux journées
reste une semaine
ça dépend je fus des trois fois ce que
j'en avais marre mais un peu
devant ma mère moi je m'étais interrogé
sur ce mot fermé pourquoi pourquoi on
appeler ça comme ça on a répondu
peut-être que je devrais pas le dire
mais tant pis c'est trop tard que on
avait employé cet adjectif fermé pour
rassurer la population mais avant tout
on est un centre éducatif sans que voilà
à nous à nous professionnels d'ouvrir
et dont l'effet celui de marseille
pratiquer l'ouverture sur l'extérieur
mais ce n'est pas le cas de tous les cef
de france certains ont une politique
beaucoup plus strictes
ce contraste entre les différents
centres éducatifs fermés en fait des
lieux controversé
[Musique]
il existe aujourd'hui 52 cf
dans le cadre d'une réforme de la
justice le gouvernement prévoit donc
créé 20 nouveaux d'ici 2022
le ministère de la justice a donc saisi
pour avis la cncdh commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme
on l'a vu dispositif fonctionne et nous
avons entendu quantité de praticiens de
gens de terrain nous avons vu aussi un
cf qui fonctionnait bien mais aussi
d'autres cf et beaucoup de cf qui
fonctionne très mal
dans son avis la cncdh décrit les cff
comme des cocottes minute où des jeunes
au parcours difficile forcés de
cohabiter finissent par exploser
elle s'inquiète du turn over des équipes
dont des centres où il est difficile de
recruter des éducateurs la cncdh
considère que les cff sont un échec pour
une première raison ils sont clos et on
a pas on n'apprend pas à vivre en
société
sauf sanctions pénales d'emprisonnement
dans un endroit fermé où le le geste
éducatif est extrêmement dit fier le
projet éducatif texte extrêmement
difficile est d'autant plus difficile
que les personnels dcf tourbe et les cff
qui fonctionne ce sont les élèves qui
ont réussi à stabiliser leur personnel
et qui ont en même temps pratiqué
l'ouverture de temps en temps du cf
et donc quand le ciel ce n'est plus un
cf ça fonctionne un constat d'échec
partagé par beaucoup d'éducateurs en
charge de l'enfance délinquante
[Musique]
au milieu d'une manifestation de
fonctionnaires
un syndicat d'éducateurs est venu donner
de la voix il s'opposait la création de
20 nouveaux cf annoncées par le
gouvernement
d'après leurs calculs à raison de 2,5
millions d'euros par nouveau cf
la mesure coûterait 50 millions d'euros
une somme qu'il serait plus utile
d'investir selon eux dans les structures
de milieu ouvert
en tout 50 millions d'euros qui vont
être consacrés à l'enfermement en
sachant que les milieux ouverts tous
kial de travail éducatif en amont qui
permet d'éviter à l'enfermement et la
prison eh bien on manque cruellement de
moyens
un peu plus de 480 jeunes sont
aujourd'hui placés on cf
chaque prise en charge coûte 660 euros
par jour à l'étain controversé le plus
coûteux des dispositifs de la justice
des mineurs a forcément attiré
l'attention de la mission d'information
sénatoriale
pour juger de l'opportunité de créer 20
nouveaux cf
les sénateurs ont visité celui de
savigny sur orge en région parisienne
ouvert il y a dix ans l'établissement
mise sur la zone pédagogie apprendre à
vivre ensemble
en observant les animaux oui rayssac
avait déjà senti mal on va faire un pic
où vous allez avoir un petit cours
chèvre rats chiens loups des animaux
choisis pour leurs comportements sociaux
nous on a pris le parti au sein de sa
vie ni de d'observer d'émeutes en fait
en groupe pour voir comment chaque place
à son importance et que à partir de là
confronté aux limites naturelles ils
prennent conscience que les limites loin
les enfermer ça peut les rendre libres
et responsables face à l'animal ils sont
pas jugés du coup il se révèle vraiment
tels qu'ils sont et là on fait un
travail éducatif grêle comme aux cff de
marseille
les journées sont rythmées par un emploi
du temps individualisé donc voilà donc
ils ont leur emploi du temps par semaine
et donc il faut le respecter c'est à
dire nous aussi on s'engage envers eux
ce qui joue un peu là dessus
s'ils ont changé ce n'est pas écrit vise
maintenant regardez moi c'était parce
que je devais faire donc ils sont très
exigeants avec nous et ce qui est très
bien d'ailleurs
ça nous permet aussi une fusion avec eux
mais aussi oeufs sont très exigeants par
rapport à ceux qui disent il faut fermer
si je peux dire les centres éducatifs
fermés
d'accord pour les remplace par quoi il
est certain que les jeunes qui sont
prises en charge dans un lieu comme
celui là le paraissent prise en charge
de façon beaucoup plus satisfaisante
quand on passe à leur insertion comme je
vous le disais à l'instant que deux
heures
une prison avec un quartier pour mineurs
ou dans un noeud pme créent vent nouveau
cf
aujourd'hui à l'issue de cette visite
j'ai envie de dire oui mais il y a
encore des exemples de cf qui ne
fonctionne pas je crois qu'il faut
prendre ce qu'ils sont vraiment faire de
lons comme celui d'aujourd'hui de de
savigny sur orge pour effectivement le
considérer comme un système de bonne
conduite
un système de bonne conduite qui ne
s'applique pas encore à tous les cff
ces dernières années plusieurs ont été
fermés suite à de graves
dysfonctionnements en fonction du lieu
de placement l'égalité de traitement
entre les jeunes n'est pas encore
garanti avant d'être envoyé en prison
dylan a d'abord été placée dans un cef
j'avais 17 ans et demi j'étais de
normandie et moi je t'ai envoyé à cholet
à côté d'angers carbone chez moi comment
s'est passé le premier jour je suis
tombé sur un jeune avec qui j'avais eu
des histoires dans soyez là qui avait
ses amis dans le f
moi j'arrivais à jeter tout ça le
lendemain ils m'ont tous mêlés j'ai fini
à l'hôpital
le nez a éclaté
[Musique]
vous êtes enfermé avec des jeunes
on va dire comme vous qu'on aime
tendance un peu si ce qu'on vous que
vous nerveux tout ça qu'on a vécu aussi
derrière parce que certains moi
franchement il ya des gars ils m'ont
parlé là bas où ils ont fait des trucs
de ouf yens la veille il avait fait du
trafic d'art au trafic de drogue
réveil rigolait pas mais ouais c'est
violent et en fait chacun en soit il est
une cocotte minute et que si tu pousses
il va péter un plomb et des coréens qui
pète un plomb sacré inlassablement
général franchement moi j'ai pas vu un
jour sans une embrouille d'abord sommes
pas forcément se battre mais sans
embrouilles y'en ai pas vus
elle s'est sortie du cf dylan a récidivé
après la prison il a de nouveau récidivé
c'est après une peine de travaux
d'intérêt général
purgez ici en milieu ouvert qu'il est
enfin sorti de la délinquance entre
l'incarcération et les cff au bilan
mitigé la justice tâtonne face aux
mineurs la privation de liberté parfois
nécessaire pour éloigner un jeune de son
milieu peut aussi s'avérer contre
productive en ferme à un gars et il aura
envie de se rebeller c'est ça que donnez
lui une chance
franchement vous venez ici je sais pas
mieux de venir ici se faire son taf on a
fait au hockey on a fait une connerie
faut payer tout le monde doit payer
quand il fait une connerie mais enfermé
un gars c'est trop facile et seront
rapides en gros on évite le problème en
fait en tout en fermant les gens parce
que le gars il va ressortir ce sera
exactement pareil que je suis leur a
aucune base que si la personne a pu
faire sa peine
en même temps elle apprend un truc c'est
pas tout le monde ici il arrive et vos
débuts vous testez ils vont faire les
beaux tout ça et vous de tester tout le
monde hier paris l'échangé n'a pas un
cratère paris les champs et les faire
changer c'est impossible
[Musique]
ce